you won't be able to find porto rosso
anywhere on a map
but you can find a place called cinque
terre that looks just like it
this seaside italian town is the
location the film was based on
as for the name it's a reference to the
film purkoroso
a japanese animated movie from the 90s
the isolated kingdom of corona entangled
was created to look just like most
michel a real title island and world
heritage site in normandy
paradise falls in the movie up is based
on an actual paradise
venezuela is home to angel falls which
happens to be the highest oversea
waterfall in the world
hiking up and down the hills of pacha's
village and the emperor's new group
would be exhausting
but the fact is thousands of people do
just that every year in cusco peru
machu picchu is a real-life wonder of
the world definitely fit for an emperor
if the new orleans bayou and princess
and the frog seem too good to be true
you're in luck the dreamy location was
actually just an ode to the real-life
lakes and rivers of louisiana